I have five different chronic illnesses,
and my husband has been on a weight loss journey the last few years
and has lost about 80 pounds.
And so
these are some things that are some non negotiables in our house.
We switch from seed oils to more natural fats.
We use cast iron skillets and stainless steel pans,
and then I use Castor soap to clean everything in our household.
Another thing that's really important,
important to Jacob and I is getting holistic therapies done,
and it has been so good for both of us.
Jacob did the magnusphere here,
and I did some brain training along with some chiropractic work,
which is so necessary.
Everything that we've implemented in our marriage
is exercising together. Whether that be walking,
running, or playing pickleball,
we like to stay very active together.
The last switch that we've made is more natural caffeines like matcha.
I've been on matcha obsession this year,
and it has not disappointed in the slightest.
I am obsessed with matcha.
More details in the caption.